- La voiture à hydrogène est
promise au plus bel avieieieieie
d'écologistes, c'est maintenant
celui de la planète entière :
l'hydrogène vert, l'énergie
prop
qui peut alimenter tout aussi
bienmomomonde du transport que
celui de l'industrie lourde.
Le pro
qu'on est encore très loin
de la e e e aux lèvres.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, HEC Mtl
Chaire dèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèà
la fois un rêve et une réalité.
On penenen produire,
on en produit au Québec.
Air Liquide a des installations
dectctctctctctctctctctctctctctcr
de 20 mégawatts, mais
t t t à très petite échelle.
- On produit actuellement
Le gris à partir de combustibles
fossiles, donc pananants.
Le bleu, plus propre, à partir
de gaz naturel, dont le CO2 a
l'hydrogène vert, à partir
d'eau et d'électricité.
c'est qu'il faut énormément
d'électricité propre pour
- Pour produire de l'hydronenene
vert, il faut avoir des
infrastructures de pro
d'électricité renouvelable.
Et il y en a au Québec,
il y en a en Nor
il y en a en Islande.
Mais il y en a pas à grande
échelle dans
et cette électricité est déjà
utilisée à d'autres fins.
- L'hydrogène vert est également
à produire que l'hydrogène gris.
Résultat : 92 % de la production
mondiale est encore réalisée
Un consortium canadien, GH2,
prévoit terminer20202024
la construction à Terre-Neuve
d'une usine d'hydrogène
pour fournir les marchés
européens et surtout
l'Allemagne.
- Dans le monde de l'hydrogène,
il y a eu beaucoup
d'anticipation et de hâte et
parce que les astres n'étaient
pas enlignés. Mais aujourd'hui,
avec l'importance qu'on accorde
on a quand même différents
éléments qui sont prometteurs.
Mais encore une fois,
l'hydrogène ne sera pas
une solution magique.
- Selon le GIEC,
dans le meilleur des cas,
l'hydrogène vert représentera,
à la fin du s
à peine 5 % de toute l'énergie
utilisée sur Terre.
Ici Normand Grondin